hey youtubers is Charlie so this week on
Game of Thrones we finally got to see
Tyrians trial we got to see Mark Gatiss
as character and we got a really awesome
Daenerys moment from the books all I
could think after the episode though was
Game of Thrones Law & Order quick shout
out for the giveaway if you're finding
me for the first time I do a weekly Game
of Thrones giveaway all you have to do
to participate is be a subscriber and
leave a comment below it's just my way
of saying thank you to all you guys for
being so awesome I'll pick a random
person and I'll announce who the winner
is in my Q&A video tomorrow night so
because we're in the back half of the
season I'm gonna do my top five moments
and then you know pick up any remaining
plot threads that didn't make it into
those then do my review careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
yet but here we go number five the iron
bank will have its due it was so awesome
to finally get to visit Braavos we
didn't see a lot of the city outside of
the iron bank but I talked about some of
the other big locations in my bonus
video so I'll have a link to that at the
end but really the important takeaways
from the bank scene is that the iron
bank is funding Stannis not because it
cares about Tommen being a bastard but
because the bank only trusts Tywin
Lannister and because they're sold on
the fact that Tywin might die of old age
soon they just don't have any faith in
the people that would replace him
everyone else in King's Landing is
terrible at managing a kingdom so
Stannis is the only viable contender for
the throne that actually has the skills
to rule and very big and pay back the
dead so they gave him more money to
raise another army and buy more ships
and in the process Marcius you know
slipped in some nice references to old
events he totally called out Davos for
all those ships resting at the bottom of
Blackwater which was actually a pretty
big ouch I mean one of his sons is down
there too you know it really was Davos
that did all the heavy lifting in the
meeting him showing his missing finger
joints was evidence of Stannis's
commitment to honoring debts
I'll bet though that if Stannis doesn't
repay his new debt as well as the
Crown's pre-existing debt they'll take
his finger joints just like he took from
Davos also quick shout out to saldo
horse and who is back and is not relate
our friend anymore my friend number 4
drogon destroys the goat herd really
awesome scene from the book but there
was a really big change in the book
those bones were of the goat herders
child the picture on my television set
was kind of fuzzy but I thought I did
see a little boys ribcage
but I did not see a skull and whenever
she offered to pay him back for his
trouble there's nothing on her face that
looks like the regret you would see
whenever your baby kills another baby
plus during that scene whenever drogon
crested the hill we really only saw him
burnt goats we didn't see him burn the
actual child but I don't think that they
could have done that on television even
if they wanted to it was a very brief
but a very big moment for establishing
the Daenerys dragons do as they please
and they're starting to Menace the
countryside so it's only gonna get worse
from here but because of that moment we
also got to see his doors oh lorac he
had a pretty big speaking role so I
think that's a good sign that he'll be
back soon if you're not familiar with
this character he's the son of one of
the former slave masters those are the
wealthy families of Marines so he has a
lot of influence in the city I'll talk
about him more the next time we seem in
an episode but let me know in the
comments below do you think they should
have included a line about those being
child's bones number 3 starting to get a
little bit more disturbing here my name
is reek I've been waiting so long for
him to start saying that essentially the
whole Yara Ironborn invasion was meant
to show us just how complete wreaks
transformation has become the Theon that
we knew is completely gone he's even
forgotten what a bath is like don't
forget that he also lives with the dogs
now and looks like he enjoys it I really
liked how uncomfortable that bath scene
felt to but that's really how we're
supposed to feel we're supposed to feel
horrified the real twist is that Ramsay
is going to use Theon to take back
Winterfell by play acting as Theon
Greyjoy you know only someone is mad as
Ramsay he could come up with a plan like
that my name is reek it rhymes with
freak so everyone posts your favorite
reek rhyme in the comments below and
number 2 Tyrians trial begins I'm just
talking about the first half of the
trial - it's like Cersei found every
person at court the Tyrion ever looked
sideways at Sir Meryn Trant was getting
revenge for Tyrion threatening to kill
him back at season 2 you know whenever
Joffrey was gonna shoot Sansa with that
crossbow maester pycelle claims that
Tyrion stole the strangler poison from
his store it's whenever he threw him in
the black cells also from season 2 then
Cersei spit that joy to ashes speech
back in his face also from season 2
Blackwater but then when various was
talking out against him he was talking
about his season 3 moment it was after
the red wedding when they were having
that small council meeting
and Joffrey was trying to celebrate
having pulled it off so the interesting
thing about that is that yes the trial
is awful and they're just steamrolling
him but he did actually say all those
awful things the only exception is is
that he did not steal any of my cells
poison so that was the only time someone
was actually lying about something he
did and my number one WTF moment tyrion
confesses Tyrians outburst really was
like the best performance in the episode
if there's an acting contest going on
between the cast members Peter Dinklage
just wanted and just to be clear he was
not confessing to killing Joffrey that
was another change from the books he
actually does confess to killing Joffrey
in the books but on the show he just
causes a huge scene in demands trial by
combat
remember that's actually how he met
Bronn in the Eyrie during season one
moondoor shoutout so I considered shade
lying about him to be a second part of
the trial that was just awful the big
thing though is that the outburst
through Jaime's bargain with Tywin out
the window but you have to consider
there are two really important things
going on you know one shay is clearly
being manipulated by Cersei to lie did
you see how many times she glanced at
her during her speech and to Tywin is so
rigid in sticking to the rules that he
can't save Tyrion anymore he has to
allow this trial by combat to commence
he really was gonna honor that promise
to Jaime which is why I love Game of
Thrones so much you know a group of
characters can have the greatest plan in
the world but then one character could
just say [ __ ] it it everything just goes
to [ __ ] that's how Ned Stark ended up
losing his head remember in that
instance Joffrey was the one that went
rogue and it's also how Theon got into
trouble whenever he left to sack
Winterfell he could have just stayed and
been Prince for the rest of his life but
nope so let that be a lesson if you're a
character on Game of Thrones and you're
part of someone's elaborate plan do not
go rogue it will not go well so now it's
your turn let me know in the comments
below what was your biggest WTF moment
you know wasn't getting to see Braavos
for the first time was it Tyrians trial
or was it seeing reek I mean really it
really has been depressing to have to
watch his scenes it's so horrible what's
going on with him
the only real plot lines that I want to
mention that didn't make it into my top
five was Oberyn secret mission to kill
the mountain there was a really nice
shout out for Team [ __ ] the king and
that small council meeting - I just love
the various had to say it out loud
remember because of that there is a
bounty on the Hound now
so more people will be trying to kill
him and they do not know that Ari is
with him Oberon was one of the few
people throughout this whole trial that
seemed impartial and his ears really did
perk up when he heard trial by combat
and we haven't seen some of those fight
scenes from him that were in the trailer
yet so we could be seeing those in the
next episode if there are any other big
plot threads that you want to talk about
that I didn't mention just write them
below in the comments but overall the
episode was another solid a just
everyone was amazing in it all the
actors including Mark Gatiss just so
much fun
Mycroft and Braavos that's all I could
think about I really hope he comes back
soon Peter Dinklage was the real homerun
of the episode though he did this
interview where he and Nikolaj
coster-waldau talked about joking around
whenever they had to film those trial
scenes they said that because it was so
emotionally demanding on them and the
days were so long they just tried to
blow off some steam by burning a couple
takes with them skipping down the aisle
and laughing you know with Tyrion
wearing the chains but the funny part is
is that the whole crew just looked
daggers at them and no one on the set
laughed those crew members do have to
work like 18 hours a day so we can't
really blame them for not laughing it
Tyrians antics I've been so impressed
this season though with how the
producers have been able to include all
these holy [ __ ] moments you know without
things getting completely out of control
it's like we're getting four or five
black water level episodes instead of
just one or two also they've even
started scouting locations for season
five but I'll talk about that in a
separate video in the teaser for the
next episode episode 7 we did see the
new mountain so we'll probably get to
see Tyrion's trial by combat and it
looks like Sansa gets another peek at
the moon door so be sure to subscribe to
get my video I'll also be posting my Q&A
video tomorrow night just like normal so
right now you can click here to get that
I'll add the Q&A annotation as soon as I
post it and you can click here to learn
all about Braavos that was what my bonus
video was today thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tomorrow
high fives
[Music]